were you faithful to her
I do not want to stand in front of Allah
and Allah asks me Ali what did you do
for me and I say oh Allah and it says
you are a liar you are a liar you did it
for the fame you did it for the money
you did it for the views
guys I'm in front of the Kaaba what I'm
about to say is not made up imagine you
watch this video and donate 100 pounds
for 10
from 10 of them only one just comes to
the Kaaba and praise all their Salah for
four days praise the janaza praise the
jummah praise them praise all their five
salons every single Salah is equivalent
to a hundred thousand and guess who gets
a reward you
you literally taught them how to pray by
donating this guided prayer so do not
miss on this reward click the button or
the link and donate now
when this was quite fast this year
didn't it
Panama
yeah yeah
it is a smart man span Allah have you
reached it yet bro
yeah we have actually oh we used it yeah
oh okay let me start the video then
okay guys so I've reached 1 million
subscribers
um I don't know what you're expecting
you know you should like clap jump you
know what should I do should I be happy
um
and it's true we should say
alhamdulillah all praise belong to Allah
but there's I'm gonna have a heart heart
with you guys I'm gonna be very honest
and brutal for the 10 years I've been in
the dawa and the lessons that I've
learned and I'm being brutally honest
for the sake of the future generation of
I'll say YouTube it's honestly Duart I
don't class myself as a Duart people
call me that I prefer actually I'm even
thinking of changing my name to Ali
needs tower on the YouTube channel and
I'm being quite brutally honest
in my hand
I know there's an opinion that you can
take an off by the guitar of Allah so
I'm going to take it off because
everything I'm about to tell you guys
it's genuinely from the heart and
genuinely philosophical Allah anything
that I say wrong is from shaytan and
myself anything good is from Allah I
take an oath buy this kitab the Allah
sent
and I swear upon the rubber of the Kaaba
everything I'm about to say is inshallah
true and the lessons that I learned and
some things you guys might not know but
it's important for me to mention this to
you guys
now brother and sisters when I first
came to Islam it's in Speaker's Corner I
had no intentions of doing videos I met
brother imranabin mansourman may Allah
bless him and his family
when I was kicked out my house they
aided me they shouted me they looked
after me they played the massive role
um may Allah bless him and preserve him
he encouraged me to do videos he
encouraged me and obviously depends
maybe some people might say to him you
know maybe you should have not but
anyways inshallah everything that I do
of good he benefits from inshallah but
anyway so he told me to do videos and I
said to him Aki I'm happy with comments
because I'm just having a dialogue I'm
not I'm not really a camera guy I don't
want to be on camera you said no look
you know what's wrong Etc anyways I
decided to start recording my
discussions
uh short story inshallah long story
short and one light Allah my witness and
I've taken off by this GitHub
I taken off by the speech of Allah in
this in this book subhanallah brothers
and sisters that I had no intentions
ever to make money your future ever
I had no intentions of views of this
stuff I genuinely love doing dawah and
that's what I wanted to do now does this
mean because you didn't start with that
intention that your intention doesn't
change no way I would be a liar if I
came and said to you my intentions don't
change everybody's intention changed you
have some days that are for you some
days are against you I think it was Imam
Chef he said I've never fought with
anything so hard except my intentions
one day is for me the next day is
against me and voila this is exactly the
case anybody who's in the YouTube scene
Who's involved in Tower or not if anyone
come and says to me I have no intention
problems I'll say to him you have the
biggest intention problems if you can
come and say I I'm sure of myself
everybody has intention problems
brothers and sisters
and along my journey Brown sisters
there's many things I learned one thing
that I saw disturbing to my like to me
was as my numbers grew my subscriber
base grew you know we fit a million now
and even before that I have never ever
followed or had an aim if I had the aim
of reaching a million or reaching half a
million I have no concern if it reaches
and reaches I have no concern of because
some people were commenting on the video
saying yeah Ali put some more videos
you're needing a million and I was
thinking I don't care well I I don't
care if I reach a million it means
nothing why because brothers and sisters
why are we so sure how do I know this
one million subscribers is good for me
how do you know how do you know that new
reaching 1 million means Allah please
means with me why do we get this
understanding from do you know where to
get it from our uncle I always mention
this over the knuckle we think just
because in the materialistic World
things are increasing I reach a million
I've got this many views how do I know
number one it's genuinely for the sake
of Allah number two how do you know
Allah accepted it I'm a human being I
make mistakes a lot of mistakes but
brothers and sisters genuinely from my
heart I want nothing but good if there's
one thing that I can say I know about
myself
I hope I'm correct Allah knows me better
that I want goodness for everybody I
don't look at anybody with evil intent I
don't know how can I see his downfall
let me see him personally there's only
one thing that I know of myself that I
can vouch for genuinely I do this for
the love of it and number two Ali needs
Tower I do this because it keeps me in
check brothers and sisters today we're
going to do an appeal for salaam I'm
around practicing beautiful Brothers if
I wasn't doing Tower I might be going
and committing sins I do this because it
keeps Ali in check if Ali was not
involved in dawah I would be God not
doing what since Allah protects me and
in this journey if people can benefit
and I inshallah that's the biggest
achievement for me all of my public
needs guys I see at null and and some of
you guys may think in subhanallah
Brother Ali he seems so humble once
again if I I was in double Minds about
speaking about this because I might
sound humble while Allah is my witness
forgive me if I sound like that I'm just
being genuine with you guys
my intentions my own sisters is not to
sound humble but be real with you guys
and I have to so this keeps me in check
guys because you know why because if I'm
involved in that one I have to be around
people who do dawa I need to study
materials to dawa I need to do that so
it keeps me in check but brothers and
sisters in this journey people have come
to me and said Ali you're Ali dawah
why'd you yeah you should have a certain
the way you carry yourself the way you
talk the way you have expectations
people were coming to me and saying you
know you should act a bit more like and
I said what do you mean by that I didn't
understand what you mean by acting and
behaving what does that mean I mean
should I be and this connects to
monetary things by the way because some
people will come and complain about me
and Mohammed hijab and be like for
example my sponsors I have sponsors
brothers and sisters and these sponsors
online none of them have gone and found
them I've never gone to anybody else can
you be my sponsor they have come to me
and I said Baba we're not employable
individuals yeah I used to do Uber so
whatever you want to give is totaled up
to you but people will come and say oh
you're under charging this that you know
people come and say oh how much do you
charge to let's say somebody else and
they'll say oh I want this much for this
video and they'll say yeah but what
about hijab and they've got more
followers but they're charging less than
that people will be upset probably you
should put the markup and I'm thinking
you're Aki and this is the point I want
to come to people have turned that one
like it's their dad's business like it's
their dad's money
there are people who feel entitled and
I'm not giving names to anybody
that one is not your dad's it doesn't
belong to you it's a manner given by
Allah to you you cannot act and behave
we hear stories of people coming to give
speech talks and charging thousands of
pounds
they've been asking I want me and my one
and my two wives to be thrown out in
business class
who the hell do you think you are
who the hell do you think you are this
isn't a manner for you to serve the Deen
this isn't a manner for you to serve the
community now there is another extreme
which is eat grass no charge that's
another extreme
yes no that's you that's the whole
extreme oh sorry I feel the same stuff
no no it's not actually I'm far from
that
sorry and the Other Extreme is eat grass
don't charge anything Etc no there are
duats you have to make a living they
have to provide for their family
subhanallah that's the Other Extreme
brothers and sisters there are times I
hear one life stories of people who are
working for Charities and they are
charging percentages 30 20 you know what
that means and there are some very rare
individuals by the way I don't want to
encourage discourage you guys from
giving donations charging 20 30 yeah
actually you are in the same breath
saying Allah the messenger Allah said if
you give to us and often you'll be like
this in heaven how are you lifting those
two fingers up when you know you're
taking 30 of the author's money
now am I saying this Haram no
no
opinion that it shouldn't be done
and I'm not trying to blast anybody but
the point is this I'm being real I don't
care if you hate me I don't care
it's disturbing now can somebody work
for a charity
that you get paid by their cost outside
of the funds and get 100 is totally fine
you're employed by them you're 100 no
problem decent amount not above I want
five six thousand pounds a month please
brothers and sisters there was a time
where I gave my I can't remember what it
was I think yes it was my it was my
YouTube yeah I give my YouTube platform
to a brother and sister yeah they wanted
to use it to raise funds and they raise
funds and then some issue happen and the
brother one of the brothers from the
organization the charity reason Franco
came to me and said yeah brother you
know you're charging too much I don't
think what's he talking about I said
yeah he's like you know it was too much
they didn't raise enough I'm saying what
what about I said I don't know what
you're talking about and then he said to
me this I said brother I'm not getting
charged for that I let them use my
platform and he's like yeah but they're
charging us and I was shocked while I
was shocked I didn't know that my
platform was being used which I gave I
said look and use it but he was under
the impression that I'm I'm getting a
cut out of it and I said okay I didn't
ask for no money I keep my platform use
it and I was so Disturbed these are the
things that's happened to brothers and
sisters we get complacent in the dawah
this is the amount of Allah this is not
a money machine it has been turned into
a business so my stolen Speakers Corner
I see Brothers may Allah bless them
preserve them yeah I believe I have very
bad sometimes my intention need to be a
check so I'm not trying to have a God
people and being the Mr righteous people
are fighting over Clips let me record
the miracle are you fighting over Cliffs
brother like you're fighting for clips
that I need to get I understand everyone
has to earn a living but brothers and
sisters you're fighting over a video are
you here to do dawa you know there's
nothing wrong yes record it you make
some kind of living understandable
you're putting effort in people I'm
hearing people swearing at each other's
mother I'm so sorry I saw two brothers
arguing otherwise a Muslim prays he's
the cause in the park saying save your
mother is mother one lie I was shocked
because about a video
and then subhanallah there was times a
couple of years ago I will invite a
brother okay can you come and um
do this how much you're paying
and money is not an issue and I said
brother for example I can't afford this
and he did not come
I don't know if you didn't come for that
reason or not but Allah but he seemed a
bit like
yeah can you not come that's why I can
afford to the organization afford that
forgive me any
subhanallah
these expectations these like I have to
like I'm in the tower while life the
fact that Allah chose you the fact that
you're doing dawah the fact that you're
calling to Allah's path is more than
enough that we should spend money to but
I understand not everyone's situation is
different I am not against those who are
getting paid for their services 100
imams these people should be paid
properly not peanuts they are underpaid
I am not talking about that brothers and
sisters we have to be just I'm sorry for
this rant but brothers and sisters I'm
being genuinely honest I'm sorry if you
wanted to watch this video of me being
happy and while I look let me be honest
I am grateful and happy with may Allah
bless you guys for supporting me may
Allah bless you guys for watching my
videos I appreciate and value that but
while I I genuinely don't believe that
the direction that we are going towards
is the direction it should be and once
again this one million subscribers I'll
be honest what am I going to enter
Jannah am I going to use my 1 million
subscribers I don't think so I encourage
every single one that's watching this if
you're someone who's a public influencer
feel and this goes to me first anything
I'm telling you I am going through these
issues myself
please please brother and sisters Allah
will take this away from you like this
Allah doesn't need any single one of us
none of us need none of us are needed by
Allah he can replace Us in an instance
when it comes to your dealings with the
people yes and myself look sometimes I
feel very harsh there's mistakes I've
made and I will carry on making them
forgive me but the point is this guys
this Tower is not a joke this is a man
given by Allah and you will be
questioned yeah do not think you're
subscribers your likes your comments
your Fame when I walk around many people
come can I take pictures with you
said he said may Allah forgive you you
know those people are saying taking a
picture with me those people who are
putting in a pedestal like I'm some kind
of a champion may Allah forgive you guys
for what you do may Allah forgive me for
what you do not know about me and may
Allah make me better than what you think
of me you know why because brothers and
sisters I'm a human being yeah yes I
might have done a video that might have
impacted your life alhamdulillah that's
good may Allah bless you I have no doubt
that my videos and many brothers videos
impact your life but I don't want to be
someone who's a candle who is giving
light to someone else while I am
finishing myself I do not want to stand
in front of Allah and Allah asks me Ali
what did you do for me and I say oh
Allah and it says you are a liar you are
a liar you did it for the fame you did
it for the money you did it for the
views
I fear that day
and wallahi I see all this time with
null if there's one thing that I rely on
brothers and sisters and I give you as a
one million with it one million as a
benefit for you to get the one million
concentrate on your private Deeds
concentrate on your private Deeds do as
much private Deeds as you can as much as
possible because that is the only thing
that you know on your Lord knows do not
rely on your public Deeds if my public
Deeds are accepted by Allah
alhamdulillah if it's rejected I don't
even rely on it I will not even come to
Allah you know why I don't know one day
it's for me one day it's against me I
have intention problems I have many
issues so all I wanted to say was that
brother sisters I know you might have
expected this one million to be a
surprise party drinking I don't know you
know can't drink with fasting you know
celebration sorry I'm just being genuine
honest with you guys I'm sorry if you
came across as negativity but we have to
keep each other in check inshallah and I
want to thank every single one of you
guys for supporting this project this
work inshallah and what you see behind
me is the marriage documentary brothers
and sisters inshallah which will be
coming out soon and we'll be doing a
seven City tour around the UK so we can
benefit you guys at home that's all I
wanted to say may Allah preserve us and
preserve you wonder inshallah if you can
make Dua for every single die and duat
that Allah purifies the intentions and
accepts our Deeds till next time from
Ali needs tawa with a 1 million
subscribers
huh
Ali Ali needs Dua and dawa yes